أجنبي ،
لديه انفجارات ، معارك ملحمية أكبر
من مشاهد الحركة الحية ورجل
يصارع نمر
أحدث أفلام الهند Blockbuster RR صعود
Roar Revolt كان يصنع موجات حول
العالم تنتصر على ريهانا ، وحصل
تايلور سويفت على الموسيقى التصويرية في Golden
Globes RR على جائزة أفضل نسخة أصلية
أغنية لحلف الناتو ،
فيلم الحركة الخيالي الذي يدور حول الحياة الواقعية للثوار
الهنود الذين يقاتلون ضد
الاستعمار ، حصل على ترشيح لجائزة الأوسكار ، وهي
لحظة نادرة
لفيلم هندي تراه عندما شرعنا في البداية
في جعلنا لا نضع
في الاعتبار الإشادة النقدية التي وضعناها في الاعتبار  لجعل
الفيلم للجمهور ليحبه لهم
لتجربة فيلم ،
حقق RR بالفعل أكثر من 150
مليون دولار في جميع أنحاء العالم وبقي لمدة
16 أسبوعًا في قائمة أفضل 10
أفلام غير إنجليزية تمت مشاهدتها على Netflix.
شركة هي نسمة من
الهواء النقي للجمهور الأمريكي ،
هناك شيء جديد وفريد ​​من نوعه
حول هذا الموضوع حيث أعتقد أنه سيكون
من الصعب القيام به إذا حاولت هوليوود القيام بذلك ،
فسيكون من الصعب استعادة هذا
البرق في الزجاجة التي
يبدو عليها هذا الفيلم  من أجل القيام
بالمخرج rajamouli معروف
بمشاهده الحماسية والمتطرفة ،
تبلغ ميزانية الشركة 68
مليون دولار مما يجعلها واحدة من
أغلى الأفلام الهندية حتى الآن أقل بكثير من
معظم
أفلام هوليوود التي حققت نجاحًا في الخارج حيث يتم
الاحتفال بها في الوطن رئيس وزراء الهند
هنأ مودي شخصيًا صانعي
الأفلام بعد فوزهم بجوائز
غولدن غلوب قائلاً إن هذا
التكريم المرموق جعل كل هندي يفتخر جدًا بأن
هوليوود فتحت أبوابها أمام
الأفلام غير الإنجليزية في السنوات الأخيرة ،
مثل الطفيليات التي أصبحت أول
شركة لغات أجنبية تفوز بجائزة الأوسكار.  إن
ترشيح جائزة الأوسكار لأفضل نقاد فيلم crr
يدفع الحدود ،
لكنه يفعل بالفعل شيء لم
يفعله أي فيلم هندي آخر على الإطلاق ، إنه
نوع
من قفزة هائلة في الوعي بأن
هناك شيئًا ما يسمى السينما الهندية
وأن هناك  سيكون هناك الكثير من
الاهتمام بالمضي قدمًا في
الفوز بجوائز الأوسكار سيكون
أول فيلم هندي وفيلم تاريخي
مع سي إن إن نيودلهي